.
GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON.
I'M BRET BAIER BREAKING TONIGHT
THE GROWING DEBATE OVER WHETHER
TO REVIVE MAST MASK MANDATES
BECAUSE OF THE CONTROVERSIES
RESURGENCE.
THE DELTA VARIANT IS SENDING
INFECTION RATES AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS UPWARD ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WHILE VACCINATION
NUMBERS REMAIN STAGNANT.
SOME OF PRESIDENT BIDEN'S PAST
ASSURANCES ABOUT THE VACCINE ARE
NOW UNDER SCRUTINY.
WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT PETER
DOOCY STARTS US OFF TONIGHT LIVE
FROM THE NORTH LAWN, GOOD
EVENING, PETER.
>> Peter: GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THE PRESIDENT JUST CONFIRMED HE
IS WAITING RIGHT NOW TO HEAR
BACK FROM A 25 PERSON WHITE
HOUSE COVID-19 ADVISORY BOARD
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT THE
GUIDANCE SHOULD BE UPDATED.
FEDERAL GUIDANCE SHOULD BE
UPDATED TO ASK PEOPLE TO WEAR
MASKS EVEN IF THEY ARE
VACCINATED.
>> GOING TO BE INVESTIGATING
EVERY ASPECT OF EVERY CHANGE
THAT COULD OR MIGHT TAKE PLACE.
♪
>> EVERY TIME I HEAR THAT I'M
WONDERING WHEN HE IS COMING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Pete: THE PRESIDENT HOSTED A
LARGE MOSTLY MASKLESS INDOORS
REPORT IN "THE WASHINGTON POST"
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
MAY SOON SUGGEST MASKS FOR THE
VACCINATED.
>> THE REPORT ON IT WAS A LITTLE
BREATHLESS.
>> IN PHILADELPHIA OFFICIALS
WARN ABOUT THE DELTA VARIANT
QUOTE IT MEANS ALL OF US GOING
BACK TO WEARING MASKS IN PUBLIC.
THAT'S AS VACCINATED PEOPLE
DEVELOP MILD SYMPTOMS DESPITE
WHAT THE PRESIDENT CLAIMED.
>> THE VARIOUS SHOTS THAT PEOPLE
ARE GETTING NOW COVER THAT.
YOU ARE OKAY.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET COVID
IF YOU HAVE THESE VACCINATIONS.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE
BREAK THROUGH POSITIVE TESTS
VACCINATED STAFF AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
>> HOW MANY BREAK THROUGH CASES
HAVE YOU HAD.
>> I DON'T HAVE MORE DETAILS ON
THAT.
I WILL SEE IF THERE IS MORE WE
CAN PROVIDE.
>> Peter: TURNS OUT THAT'S A
DEAD END.
>> NO I DON'T THINK WE WILL BE
PROVIDING NUMBERS OF BREAK
THROUGH CASES.
>> Peter: GOING TO RETURN TO
INDOOR MASK MANDATES THERE
ACCORDING TO POLITICO SOMETHING
A REPUBLICAN DOCTOR WHO IS IN
CONGRESS WARNS AGAINST.
>> THERE SHOULD BE NO WIN TO
REGRESS INTO A MASKED UP
CONGRESS OR A MASKED UP STATE.
>> Peter: SO FAR CDC GUIDANCE
HAS NOT CHANGED.
>> YOU SHOULD CERTAINLY BE
WEARING A MASK IF YOU ARE
UNVACCINATED.
IF YOU ARE VACCINATED YOU GET
EXCEPTIONAL PROTECTION FROM THE
VACCINE, BUT YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THE PERSONAL
CHOICE TO ADD EXTRA LAYER.
>> Peter: THE PRESIDENT MADE IT
SOUND LIKE MASKS WERE A THING OF
THE PAST.
>> LET ME REPEAT, IF YOU ARE
FULLY VACCINATED, YOU NO LONGER
NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
>> Peter: THAT COULD CHANGE AS
VARIANTS SPREAD.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE GOT THE
VACCINE BECAUSE THEY WERE
HEARING HIM SAY IF YOU GET THE
VACCINE, YOU DON'T HAVE TO WEAR
MASKS ANYMORE.
>> AND THAT CONTINUES TO BE CDC
GUIDANCE.
>> Peter: AND CAN YOU SAY THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE GUIDANCE
FOREVER.
>> I'M NOT THE CDC DIRECTOR.
>> Peter: I WAS AT AN EVENT IN
THE EAST ROOM EARLIER TODAY,
DOZENS OF LAWMAKERS VERY FEW
MASKS BECAUSE THAT'S OKAY WITHIN
THE GUIDELINES OF THE CURRENT
CDC ADVISORY.
AND OFFICIALS AROUND HERE FOLLOW
THE CDC GUIDANCE TO A T.
EVENTS AROUND HERE COULD START
TO LOOK VERY DIFFERENT IF THAT
GUIDANCE GETS UPDATED AND IT
COULD HAPPEN AT ANY TIME.
REMEMBER, WHEN THE CDC SAID
VACCINATED PEOPLE DON'T NEED TO
WEAR MASKS ANYMORE IN THE
SPRING, THAT CAME OUT OF
NOWHERE.
BRET?
>> Bret: PETER, WHAT'S THE WHITE
HOUSE SAYING ABOUT THE NEW
ETHICAL CONCERNS ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN'S UPCOMING ART SHOW.
>> Peter: OFFICIALS ARE SAYING
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE NO
IDEA IF HE WHITE HOUSE WHO
EXACTLY IS BIDDING UP TO 6
FIGURES ON HUNTER BIDEN'S
ARTWORK.
THEY THINK THAT IS GOING TO
PREVENT PEOPLE FROM TRYING TO
SEEK INFLUENCE WITH THE
PRESIDENT THROUGH THE SON;
HOWEVER, THE GALLERY SELLING HIS
STUFF TOLD CBS HUNTER IS GOING
TO MEET WITH PERSPECTIVE BUYERS.
AND THAT CONFLICTS WITH WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE HAD SAID IN THE PAST
ESPECIALLY SINCE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT KIND OF GUARDRAILS
SPECIFICALLY ARE THERE TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYTHING IS ON THE UP AND
UP.
I REACHED OUT TO THAT GALLERY
FOR MORE INFORMATION.
BRET?